Later on on the show today, I'm going to tell
you that I believe the left is losing the
soul called
battle of ideas, but before we can even have
that conversation, we should go over the details
of the multiple mass shootings that took place
this weekend with countless casualties carried
out, uh, once again by people, at least in
one case, inspired by the ideology that underlies
support for Donald Trump and which in fact
Donald Trump himself has been fomenting, uh,
and then also a mass shooting carried out
by an apparent pro LGBT rights anti-Trump
leftist. So yes, I'm not going to sugarcoat
at one of the shooting incidents this weekend
was by an apparent left this, but we will
talk about the degree to which we can say
their ideology inspired the actual violence.
This is a really important thing to understand.
I'm getting ahead of myself. Let's take it
piece by piece. Let's go through the CIC details.
Now before we even do that, just to be clear,
we're just, it's a foregone conclusion that
all of today's show is going to be demonetized
for us on Youtube and other platforms because
these are the stories that are not considered
brand safe.
So we're going to earn no money on most of
today's stories because we're covering what
took place over the weekend. So consider leaving
a tip so to speak, become a member@joinpacman.com
because everything we're talking about today,
even tangentially, tens tangentially related
to these shootings is going to be demonetized.
So let's start with El Paso. Donald Trump
has been doing everything from threatening
Sweden to release asap rocky and American
rapper to encouraging violence at his rallies
by saying he'll pay the legal fees of people
who get arrested for roughing up protesters.
He's repeated the xenophobic language about
immigrants, particularly brown skinned ones
of all types from s whole countries in contrast
to people from Norway, who are the people
we should want coming to the United States.
And it is all now coming to a head with a
weekend that includes a mass shooting where
at least one shooter specifically claimed
that ideology as his inspiration.
The first shooting, 11:00 AM on Saturday shooter
walks into El Paso, Texas. Walmart starts
shooting around 20 killed a ton injured. We're
still trying to figure out the exact numbers
of four month old baby was killed. The suspect
was captured and not killed. In this particular
case, we have both a post from the shooter
on eight Chan, an online hub for extremism
and racism and white supremacy and we have
the shooters manifesto and I know you probably
are not surprised to hear this, but it was
yet another one of these anti-immigrant who
was pushed towards white supremacy wrote that
he agrees with the Christ church shooter's
manifesto, another anti-immigrant, xenophobic
screed. The manifesto is essentially an amalgamation
of the exact xenophobic ideas that have been
pushed by Donald Trump and the people around
him. A Hispanic invasion of the u s end of
Texas is something we need to be afraid of.
White people are being replaced by foreigners.
The great replacement theory or idea or conspiracy
theory, the shooter didn't like race mixing
and it said the manifesto about immigrants.
That quote, if we can get rid of enough people,
the a, then our way of life can be more sustainable.
It says he was inspired by the same white
supremacist anti-immigrant ideology that the
Christchurch New Zealand shooter was inspired
by and the El Paso shooter actually mentioned
the Christ church shooter. In the manifesto,
news organizations have identified a Twitter
account since taken down appearing to be the
suspect, which includes the build the wall
hashtag stuff a picture using guns to spell
out the word Trump as well as posts from a
right wing conspiracy theorist who happens
not to like me named Paul Joseph Watson, known
for his association with Alex Jones. So in
some cases these domestic terrorists and that's
what they are and that's what we should call
them if we care about facts and feelings.
That is sometimes these domestic terrorists
literally have a vehicle covered in Trump,
stuff like that. Mag a bomber who sent pipe
bombs to Democrats. Sometimes it's simply
the end point of stochastic terrorism and
radicalization that starts with sometimes
as high as the president of the United States
and the White House and the rhetoric that
we see there. Now there's a very specific
element from the manifesto that Trumpists
are pointing to in order to defend Trump,
which is that the shooter says his ideas predate
Donald Trump. Trump didn't give him these
ideas and this is super interesting. They
say that Trump has say this vindicates Donald
Trump, this is not a vindication of Trump.
This is an indictment of Trump and I'll explain
what I mean by that. I've said all along,
Donald Trump hasn't so much radicalized people.
He's in bold and and coalesced and inspired
the radicals to become more active, to be
more public and to take action around this
ideology.
This el Paso shoot or just like many others
already held most of these anti-immigrant
Zena phobic Hispanic invasion, great replacement
ideas before Donald Trump. What Donald Trump's
presidency did is number one, gave them solidarity.
As Richard Spencer told me himself, this is
a president that is as close to what they
want as they are getting and who is saying
this is the time to do your stuff, if there
was any time to do it. So number one, Trump
gave them solidarity and number two, Trump
made them much more willing to go public with
their ideas. And then third, Trump escalated
their fear that this stuff was happening and
ultimately has inspired them to take action
through that mechanism called stochastic terrorism.
That I've talked about before. The argument
for me was never that Trump is radicalizing
people who otherwise didn't hold any of these
beliefs. It's that Trump has created an environment
where the radicals become much more willing
to do things in the real world and we're seeing
it every week, month.
I mean, I dunno, it depends how you want to
categorize it. They're not creating the radicals.
They're turning the radicals into actual domestic
terrorists by emboldening them and legitimizing
their hate ideologies. Now 13 hours later
in Dayton, Ohio, another mass shooting again,
we're still getting numbers. Seems like nine
or 10 people killed around 25 injured. Those
numbers may increase in a nightclub by someone
that we now believe to be a leftist. Politically,
this suspect was killed by police. The suspect
was using a two 23 high capacity gun, had
additional magazines with them, was wearing
body armor, and in this one media is making
a big deal of how heroic police killed the
shooter so quickly, like within a minute or
a couple of minutes. Now that might sound
like a, when they're touting that as a win
and of course it's good to stop someone who
is actively trying to kill people before they
kill more people.
But consider that what this means is that
in just one minute the shooter was able to
kill nine people and injured 26 or whatever
the exact numbers are. The shooter never should
have had firearms that would have let him
kill nine people and injured 26 in one minute.
That's what we need to be understanding when
we hear about the police neutralized them
after a minute. Since the shooting, it's been
reported that the shooter described himself
on social media as he him Anamae fan metal
head leftist. I'm going to hell and I'm not
coming back. He tweeted that he would vote
for Elizabeth Warren in 2020. He tweeted that
he was upset about Trump pointing in 2016
he said, quote, I want socialism and I'll
not wait for the idiots to finally come around
to understanding. He, uh, is believed to have
been a registered Democrat and has tweeted
in favor of gun control and gun safety regulations.
Okay, so let's now go through something really
important here. We have a right wing shooter
and a left wing shooter and there are elements
of the right that even though we know that
the overwhelming majority of political violence
is right wing, they are seizing on this weekend
of a right wing shooter and a left wing shooter.
And trying to equate and say, we just have
violence from both sides and it's bad and
let's work together. I want to be really careful
here, but there's a really important distinction
that has to be made right now. It is abundantly
clear that the motivation of the right wing
shooter in El Paso was his right wing beliefs.
Specifically, he left a manifesto. He went
to a particular place that is at the center
of this battle around the issues which around
which he was radicalized immigration and Hispanic
people, et Cetera, and anti-immigrant guy
worried about a white invasion drives hours
to El Paso to do this and leaves a manifesto
telling us what radicalized him.
We simply don't know whether left wing beliefs
actually inspired the Dayton, Ohio shooter.
There is currently no evidence of that. So
believe me, this is not a show where I sugar
coat stuff. If we have terrorism from a a
Muslim radicalization, I tell you that when
we have terrorism from these militia types,
I tell you that what we know now is that the
Dayton shooter appears to have had left this
politics. We have no evidence that those beliefs
are what inspired the shooting. We have no
evidence at this point that that political,
uh, orientation was the reason for the shooting
in Dayton, Ohio. As soon as we get that evidence.
If we do, I will be right here telling you,
but that is not the information that we currently
have as of this taping and it is really important
that we not allow the rightest to say these
shootings are equivalent in that you had right
wing beliefs inspire shooting and left wing
beliefs inspire a shooting.
Unless we know that the Dayton Ohio shooting
was politically motivated violence, we should
not say that it was in some already are so
that now this is going to get us to, I believe
it is time for the left to realize that we
are losing the battle of ideas in a very disturbing
and specific way to talk to people about this
in a serious way. We have to address this
issue. We talk jokingly or satirically about
the marketplace of ideas and the battle of
ideas, but there is a really concerning and
specific way in which we are losing the battle
of ideas.
That's what I'm going to talk to you about
next,